entschuldigung wo geht's denn hier zum
ozean die autofahrerin die dieses video
aufnimmt traut ihren augen kaum ein
seelöwe auf der autobahn in san diego
die küste fast fünf kilometer entfernt
nicht ungefährlich zum glück hat der
besucher zwei mutige helfer sie geleiten
den seelöwen über die straße
zielstrebig hoffte er auf die andere
straßenseite dort stoppt ihn schließlich
die polizei
ein beamter twittert kurz darauf dieses
foto während er und seine kollegen auf
die experten vom benachbarten
freizeitpark seaworld warten sie sollen
kommen und den seelöwen in den ozean
zurückbringen wo er eigentlich zu hause
ist und wo er sich etwas wohler fühlt
als hier im trockenen gras
[Musik]
zuerst geht es aber in einem käfig in
seaworld wo eine wunde an seiner
schnauze versorgt werden soll
offenbar ist der seelöwe ein
wiederholungstäter er wurde schon bei
wanderungen in der nähe des flughafens
und eines militärstützpunktes gesichtet
zurück im wasser ist der schon wieder
deutlich munterer und hält ausschau wir
hier wieder rauskommt so ein becken ist
aber auch langweilig erst recht für
leidenschaftliche wanderer wie ihn
[Musik]